Speaker 1: So we have another signal about
this internal battle taking place between
the pro and the anti Trump wings of the Republican
Party, and it seems very clear that the pro
Trump wing is hugely winning.
Now, in the next segment, I'm going to talk
about a poll many of you e-mailed me about
saying, look at this one poll, David.
It shows Trump is not winning.
We'll get to that.
I believe when you look at the totality of
the evidence, this is still a very, very Trump
and Republican Party.
And what we're going to look at first here
is that former Trump vice president Mike Pence
was brutally booed and heckled at the Faith
and Freedom Coalition a few days ago by fellow
Trump ists.
Mind you.
Now, how wild is it that at this point, Mike
Pence, who was simply a plant, that Trump
could do whatever he wanted to do, Trump could
water pants or not or weed him or pull off
the flowers?
The guy was like an immobile plant in the
back of the room, barely sentient during the
Trump administration.
Pence is now widely seen as not Trump being
enough because he didn't, I guess, try to
steal the election on January 6th for Donald
Trump via some mechanism that is still not
completely clear to me.
And now Mike Pence is suffering the brunt
of it.
His career may be over or at least dead for
several years until he can maybe rehabilitate
it.
Check out this video of Mike Pence being called
a traitor and heckled brutally, mercilessly
during his attempted speech.
Just interruption after interruption.
Speaker 4: It is great to be back with so
many patriots dedicated to faith and freedom
and the road to the majority.
And I want to thank my friend Ralph Reed for
those overly generous words deeply involved
by Ralph Reed knows me well enough to know
he prefers a little bit shorter.
I'm a Christian conservative and a Republican
in that order.
And I am I just found
Speaker 1: it for you.
There's talk of pense 2024.
But if the guy can't even get a sentence out
about I'm a Christian patriot in front of
a right wing audience without being heckled
by that very audience, it's not looking good
for Mike Pence for 2024 and understand that
he's being called a traitor because he didn't
overtly try to violate the Constitution on
January six.
The people who claim to be all about the Constitution
are mad at Pence because he didn't find some
way around the Constitution to install Trump
for a second term.
He didn't win.
He still did Trump's bidding for four years.
He stood there.
He nodded along.
He flattered Trump.
He said, thanks to Trump.
We did this.
We did that even though it was all B.S., particularly
around the pandemic.
And he just didn't openly try to get around
the Constitution on January 6th.
And now the guy's a traitor that can't get
a sentence out.
Now we know what Pence's strategy was.
I don't feel bad for Pence.
Pence's strategy was bite his tongue, stay
quiet, stay on Trump's good side so that then
he could try to appropriate Trump appropriate
Trump's base for himself.
Whenever Trump's done, be it 2024 or whatever
the case may be, it all went in the trash
with what you could say with one act.
It's really a non act pense abstained from
trying to openly circumvent and destroy the
Constitution on January 6th.
And Pence is now an enemy to Trump.
It's plain and simple.
He was a good boy for three years, 11 months
and two weeks.
But with just two weeks left before the end
of the term, he said, Sir, I can't steal the
election and now the guy can't get a single
sentence out in front of a supposedly friendly
audience.
It is quite stunning and I don't feel bad
for the guy.
It's just amazing how reactionary and rabid
that Trump base is.
Pence made his bed at Trump as Trump's VP
and he's going to have to sleep in it now.
But a stunning series of events and also,
I mean, at this point, what is going on in
pences mind that he even continues to stand
up in front of these crowds, like even religious
right wing crowds, which are I guess is bread
and butter.
These are the same people, some of whom wanted
him dead on January six.
Remember, some of these very people are part
of the political movement that was calling
for Pence to be hanged.
Hang Mike Pence was their chant on January
6th.
Why even subject himself to it at this point?
I guess at least this crowd wasn't chanting
hang Mike Pence at this particular event.
But I see Pence's political career as completely
dead for a while.
Let me know if you disagree.
And speaking of the future of people's political
careers, let's talk about that next.